so tell me Mele is the earth flat we
have video from space of the rotating
spherical earth the earth is round thank
you for joining us on this episode
[Music]
but what's what's odd is there are
people who think earth is flat right but
recognize that the moon is round Mercury
Venus Mars Jupiter Saturn Uranus Neptune
and the Sun are all spheres but earth is
flat
that's not something doesn't square
that's a job right okay plus in my
latest book hmm your latest book is
called astrophysics for people in a
hurry well we just happen I swear we
didn't plant the book I have an entire
chapter titled on being round and it's
an exploration of how all the laws of
physics and the accounting of energy as
processes unfold in the universe how
that conspire to make things round so it
favors the sphere favors a sphere yes
and if something is not a sphere it's a
little bit flattened you can ask what's
landed and you find out oh it's rotating
real fast right so then it gets a little
flattened because of that right and so
almost everything in the universe is
either spheres or slight distortions of
a sphere for some other thing that's
happening to it I mean we can just see
how the the universe favor spheres so
its nature right basic maneuver it is
fairness to the people who want a
flatter yes let's be fair to those in
Columbus's day there was surely a flat
earth contingent yes
columbus predates the era of
experimental checking of any idea you
might have not a lot of peer-reviewed
studies on just let just say whatever
you felt you know what I believe that
elephant poop will cure cancer there you
go that's right
wrote a paper about it like to read it
here it is right right so it was until
till Francis Bacon Galileo 1600s where
the idea that if you're going to say
something and you think what you're
saying is true then no matter how
obvious you think it is that it's true
you should still test it
gotcha there could be something fooling
you in one way or another so if you want
to say earth is flat then for example
lunar eclipses what's a lunar eclipse if
your face is the brilliant Sun thank you
and this is Earth and the moon is over
here the Sun is always casting Earth's
shadow into space it's always there no
matter what right obviously okay it's
such a shadow it's a channel the moon
shining on blackness yeah a shadow in
darkest shadow and so so the moon
occasionally passes through that shadow
and if you see the shape of Earth shadow
on the moon it is always round always
round if earth were flat sometimes you
get like a flat shadow right and we've
never seen a flat shadow right in fact
it is a segment of a arc of a circle
no matter the orientation of the moon
and the Sun and the only thing that
makes a perfectly circular shadow would
be something that's perfectly circular
perfectly spherical yes so the only
thing that makes a perfect circle shadow
every single time is a perfect sphere
right okay no matter what angle and
where as a disc it would only make a
perfect circle if you lined it that way
right and then they have to look at the
face of the disc in order to get the
circle Greeks knew this right all the
lunar eclipses had a set oh my gosh we
must be in a round or this is thousands
of years before Columbus exactly so now
if the earth is round how big is Earth
you might want to check for that there's
a famous experiment conducted by
Eratosthenes Bethany ever touched the
knees there the two cities in the old
world and one of them they knew that at
12:00 noon on a particular day of the
year that the Sun was directly overhead
and you can see the bottom of a well
okay you don't run around looking at the
bottoms of wells no you net because the
light doesn't take it's just doesn't get
down it doesn't get down it how can we
use this observation to see if Earth's
surface is curved we needed another well
turns out we can't see the bottom of
both wells at the same time what might
explain this
well they're two possible explanations
first we could have a flat earth with
the Sun that's small and close by so
that the light hits the second well at
an angle or a second we could have a
curved earth with a Sun that's big and
far away so that all the light comes in
parallel but only one well at a time is
lit all the way to the bottom turns out
with just two Wells there's enough
wiggle room for both explanations to fit
our observations Eratosthenes only had
two wells but what if he had added a
third with a third well it doesn't
matter where the Sun is no flat earth
model can explain the angles of all
three shadows but the spherical model
explains it all all three angles with
ease and to do this experiment you got
to measure the angles Greeks had the
angles yeah okay in fact geometry
translates to earth measurement so one
last thing which should be obvious okay
if you pay attention and think about it
if you send a ship straight to the
horizon eventually it begins to
disappear until it's no longer visible
beyond your horizon right and you should
ask yourself what kind of surface would
produce that result if it's con ocean
has a ramp they just like going down
seafarers knew this right and so what
however flat they would have imagined
the earth to be they couldn't they
couldn't have accepted to be completely
flat because otherwise you would never
not see the ship okay also if I just
tell you chuck walk due east okay right
and don't ever stop right I just turn
around my chair and face this way and
eventually you gonna come back right and
you'll probably be about a hundred and
fifty years old I am no Forrest Gump
that is how long it would take me to run
the earth for me the fact that there's a
rise of flat earthers there's evidence
of two things okay long one we live in a
country that protects free speech that's
actually kind of Awesome and two we live
in a country where they failed education
system ooh that one hurt our system
needs to train you not only what to know
but how to think about information and
knowledge and and and and evidence if we
don't have that kind of training you'd
run around believe anything anything
anything and if you're interested in
learning more about the earth the Sun
and how the fact that we're rolling
through space at what do I what is this
17,000 miles per hour is that what we're
going to pull that number out of your
you know what I pulled it from so you
should consider all of this and consider
chucking out brilliant whether you are
an adamant defender of the Earth's
curves mmm-hmm or a professional
scientist or a lifelong learner
brilliant helps you master concepts of
math science and engineering through
solving fun challenging problems and you
can sign up for free to get access to
weekly challenges and as a bonus to
Startalk viewers anyone up to the 19th
prime number that goes to brilliant dot
org slash Startalk
will get 20% off the annual subscription
which helps you think like a scientist
through god of course material and the
ability to track progress with stats and
extra practice if you like what you see
and you want to watch more videos from
star talk hit the subscribe our and
click the little button that gets you
notifications every time that we put up
a video and don't forget to like and
comment below with the topic of your own
that you've been dying to get to the
bottom of all right so hey for those of
you who are flat earthers we say it's
okay as long as you don't run NASA and
for those of you who are Greek
philosophers and mathematicians Neil
will tell you what they would tell you
which would be I don't know Greek but if
you could translate ancient Greek into
English they would say keep looking up
[Music]
you
[Music]